President Biden getting shamed into
saying more than just no comments to the
deadly wildfires in Hawaii it's been
nearly a week since the destructive
blazes reduced entire towns to rubble
and while Hawaii was counting its dead
Biden was busy being a beach bum in
Delaware relaxing in his lounge chair
for hours and soaking up the sun today
he finally got serious about the
disaster by promising a visit and
addressing the survivors in a more
meaningful Way by reading off a
teleprompter I've spoken to Governor
Josh Green multiple times and reassured
in the state will have everything it
needs from the federal government
I immediately approved the governor's
request for expedite major disaster
declaration that's a fancy word of
saying whatever you need you're going to
get
but the damage has been done a former
Hawaii state democratic rep said he
found Biden's no comment response to be
shocking and out of character and the
president's press secretary isn't making
the administration look any more
competent after butchering the name and
gender of Hawaii Senator Maisie hirono
senator harino who I said the president
spoke to just last night he thanked the
president for the immediate support of
federal agencies have delivered for
residents of Hawaii and so does has so
has Senator Schwartz
speaking of Senator hirono she's using
the tragedy to push the Democrats
climate change agenda I think that we we
very much need to acknowledge that
climate change is upon us there are
whole states by the way Jake where you
can't even the use the words climate
change because they still have a hit in
the sand attitude
he makes a good point would you like to
go first
all right Greg okay is Hawaii getting
the seventh grandchild treatment yes I'm
not I'm not crazy about attacking like
the uh the delayed tragedy response
because everybody does it but I don't
care I'm going to do it anyway uh I
return to the most perplexing problem we
aren't asking Joe Biden to you know
write a unicycle uh you know on a narrow
rope between two skyscrapers the
requirement what we're asking for is his
wheelhouse right you know this is his
Metamucil and butter uh you know and he
can't do it this is the king of empathy
here this is the dog that's not barking
you know that old phrase he's done I
mean his wheelhouse is empathy and he's
expressing none at the time where it's
most necessary and fairly easy I mean
imagine if you turn on the five and
Harold is glum and ugly not as handsome
you would know something is wrong with
him uh there's something he's not long
for this you know what I mean I've seen
this before you know when you go to a
restaurant and the chef is just not
cooking that well anymore and you know
it's just a matter of time that's what
we're seeing there's a mass tragedy and
a designated guest at every state
funeral can't do it you know Maui's in
terrible shape but this white house
ain't much better okay Dana Biden won
Hawaii I believe it was 63 to 43.
surprise it's only 63. right what do you
see the split being this year after this
mess well I I don't well do I see any
Republicans Sweeping in saying hey we
got you no like not really like will
Kane he's on the ground there but who
else is saying yeah we will do that I
mean there's comparisons to money to
Ukraine for Hawaii but that's actually
to make a different political point if
Republicans want to get in there and say
we have ideas for you we know how to
rebuild we're going to volunteer we got
great knock yourselves out but I don't
exactly see that happening I can't get
over the press secretary not knowing
that Senator hirono first how to say her
name and that she's a woman because
she's been a senator for quite a long
time now let me tell you as press
secretary I made 100 mistakes a day
probably and my blooper reel would be
horrendous I imagine she probably called
and apologized and I'm sure it was taken
because that's a pretty tough job how do
you not know the dumbest senator
I I I don't know is that what we're
calling this yeah Charlie okay wait she
is I would like to mention something
also that you were bringing up that
Biden has this weird pattern of a lack
of empathy yeah so the East Palestine
remember this was so weird that they
couldn't even say yes we're going to go
like what was it what were they afraid
of yeah it's not hard to do this um
Afghanistan they could never say that
there were any mistakes they have to say
it was the greatest airlift in history a
baby formula that was everybody else's
problem gas prices rise it's somebody
else's problem until they go down and
then they take all the credit and they
just expect the media to cover for them
basically and last point on climate
change is that I am
I am okay saying yes maybe warmer Waters
the higher hurricanes the winds however
there is evidence that Hawaii for a long
time has been warned of wildfire risk
and there's a lot of money out there on
climate change and what was was that any
of that money used to mitigate the
Wildfire problems on this in this area
and I would say submit that when we
finally get the answer is probably not
much all right Charlie the FEMA boss
yesterday talked about the need for
culturally responsive Outreach do you
think the people in Hawaii really care
about culturally responsive Outreach no
I don't think they do at all
and uh but you know it's funny whoever
said that that uh Biden's response is
shocking but not out of character I I
would agree that it was shocking but I
would also say that his response was so
in character it's not even funny when he
says uh no comment uh and then the White
House has to later come up with a
statement saying that oh no he's
mourning he's he's in mourning but he
wasn't and and why would did he have no
comment because he didn't know what to
say maybe he didn't hear what the
reporter asked but he had no idea what
to say which is a very alarming thing
but it's also very much in character
with Joe Biden and where was he he was
at the beach he was lounging in a in a
lounge chair on the beach with the
former ambassador to to Romania I wonder
what they were talking about and and and
but that's who this guy is now and uh
and this you know for for the longest
time Democrats or in the last couple
years Democrats have had tried to
portray him as this compassionate
empathetic person and that's really not
who the guy was for 50 years in
Washington uh and so this response to me
is very in character for him you know
Harold they say the estimated impact of
the fires is 5.6 billion dollars
um you know hopefully with all the money
we're giving Ukraine we'll be able to uh
help Hawaii out since I assumed that
tourism is going to be in trouble but
Paris Hilton I think is having a good
time
no I imagine we're going to give I think
the president when he spoke with the
governor said you're going to you're
going to get what you want I would agree
with we we had this conversation
yesterday I thought Greg's point at the
start of it about you know if whoever's
in power gets criticized by those out of
power and these things and this is one
of those moments where the president
probably deserves a little criticism for
being late to to express it himself
um my advice to the White House keep the
president off the beach as we deal with
this situation in Hawaii of all places
until he's able to visit and I'm glad
that he and the first lady are going to
be able to go there Dr Biden will be
able to go there but it's not a it's not
a great visual even if he had said the
words right at the very beginning I
think at this point to be to be doing
that I give him credit still I believe
in him I hope he you know when I said
believe in him I'm glad it's better late
than never because I think you have to
live and work and hope and hopefully um
hopefully we don't we don't get caught
up in talking about climate change too
much around you got you still have
thousands of people unaccounted for you
got 25 percent of the air only 25
percent of the area has been searched
let's focus our ire and all of our
energy there and then we get back to
fighting about climate change Now is it
going with Jill or is he going with
common law I think he's going with Dr
Biden yeah thank God she's a doctor yeah
yeah she could she might be able to help
yeah seriously I went on Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now